I am a translator I translate from
biology into mathematics and vice versa
I write mathematical models which in my
case are systems of differential
equations to describe biological
mechanisms such as cell growth
essentially it works like this
first identify the key elements that I
believe may be driving behavior over
time of a particular mechanism then I
formulate assumptions about how these
elements interact with each other and
with their environment
may look something like this then I
translate these assumptions into
equations which may look something like
this
finally I analyze my equations and
translate the results back into the
language of biology a key aspect of
mathematical modeling is that we as
modelers do not think about what things
are we think about what they do we think
about relationships between individuals
whether they be cells animals or people
and how they interact with each other
and with their environment let me give
you an example
what do foxes and immune cells have in
common they're both predators except
foxes feed on rabbits and Orion cells
feed on invaders such as cancer cells
but from a mathematical point of view a
qualitatively same system of predator
prey type equations will describe
interactions between foxes and rabbits
and cancer and immune cells predator
prey type systems have been studied
extensively in scientific literature
describing interactions of two
populations where survival of one
depends on consuming the other and these
same equations provide a framework for
understanding cancer immune interactions
where cancer is the prey and the immune
system is a predator and the prey
employs all sorts of tricks to prevent
the predator from killing it ranging
from camouflaging itself to steal in the
Predators food this can have some very
interesting implications for example
despite enormous successes in the field
of immunotherapy there's
still remain somewhat limited efficacy
when it comes to solid tumors but if you
think about it ecologically both cancer
and immune cells the prey and the
predator require nutrients such as
glucose to survive if cancer cells
out-compete the immune cells for shared
nutrients in the tumor microenvironment
the new moon cells will physically not
be able to do their job this predator
prey shared resource type model is
something I've worked on in my own
research and it was recently shown
experimentally that restoring the
metabolic balance in the tumor
microenvironment that is making sure
immune cells get their food can give
them the Predators back their edge in
fighting cancer the prey this means that
if you abstract a bit you can think
about cancer itself as an ecosystem
where heterogeneous populations of cells
compete and cooperate for space and
nutrients interact with predators the
immune system migrate metastases always
in the ecosystem of the human body and
what do we know about most ecosystems
from conservation biology that one of
the best ways to extinguish species is
not to target them directly but to
target their environment and so once we
have identified the key components of
the tumor environment we can propose
hypotheses and simulate scenarios and
therapeutic interventions all in a
completely safe and affordable way aimed
at targeting different components of the
micro environment in such a way as to
kill the cancer without harming the host
such as me or you and so while the
immediate goal of my research is to
advance research and innovation and to
reduce its cost the real intent of
course is to save lives and that's what
I try to do through mathematical
modeling applied to biology and in
particular to the development of drugs
it's a field that until relatively
recently has remained somewhat marginal
but it has matured and there are now
very well developed mathematical methods
a lot of pre-programmed tools in
every once and an ever-increasing amount
of computational power available to us
the power and beauty of mathematical
modeling lies in the fact that it makes
you formalize in a very rigorous way
what we think we know we make
assumptions translate them into
equations run simulations all to answer
the question in a world where my
assumptions are true what do I expect to
see it's a pretty simple conceptual
framework it's all about asking the
right questions but it can unleash
numerous opportunities for testing
biological hypotheses if our predictions
match observations great we got it right
so it can make further predictions by
changing this or that aspect of the
model
if however our predictions do not match
our observations that means that some of
our assumptions are wrong and so our
understanding of the key mechanisms of
underlying biology is still incomplete
luckily since this is a model we control
all the assumptions so we can go through
them one by one
identifying which one or ones are
causing the discrepancy and then we can
fill this newly identified gap in
knowledge using both experimental and
theoretical approaches of course an
ecosystem is extremely complex and
trying to describe all the moving parts
is not only very difficult but also not
very informative there's also the issue
of time scales because some processes
take place on the scale of seconds some
minutes some days months and years it
may not always be possible to separate
those out experimentally and some things
happen so quickly or so slowly that you
may physically never be able to measure
them but as mathematicians we have the
power to zoom in on any subsystem in any
time scale and simulate effects of
interventions that take place in any
time scale of course this isn't the work
of our modeler alone it has to happen in
close collaborations with biologists and
it does demand some capacity of
translation on both sides but starting
with a theoretical formulation of a
problem can
numerous opportunities for testing
hypotheses and simulating scenarios and
therapeutic interventions all in a
completely safe way it can identify gaps
in knowledge and logical inconsistencies
and can help guide us as to where we
should keep looking and where there may
be a dead end
in other words mathematical modeling can
help us answer questions that directly
affect people's health that affect each
person's health actually because
mathematical modeling will be key to
propelling personalized medicine and it
all comes down to asking the right
question and translating it to the right
equation and back thank you
[Applause]
[Music]